today will be about
synergizing model and human decision
making using augmented machine learning
which is quite a long title but it's
about how we collaborate how models and
humans collaborate at florence to do
decision-making
and it turns out that we're not the only
one doing this
jp morgan bankers learned to work with
expanding ai team
this was in the news last week and what
triggers me a lot about this this
headline is
with the expanding ai team bankers are
not replaced by machine learning but
they learn yeah they learn to work with
ai to improve their decision making so
the head of the ai team also said
bankers were initially skeptical of the
product because they didn't understand
its reasoning
but once they were provided with the
explanation the proportion of bankers
agreeing with the ai's recommendations
rose from 65 to 95 percent and we're
doing something similar at florence and
i will talk you through that during this
presentation
so above me i'm a data scientist at
florence for two years now i have a
background in industrial engineering
but i also studied data science
and i like to solve stuff pragmatically
which you will also see in this
presentation of course
then about the about florence the
company i work for my squad is also here
in the second row
we're an
sme lending platform so we provide
flexible credit limits to companies
there are no annual reports required
with us so you don't have to hand in
your entire
accounting history but you can just
provide us with bank statements from the
last six months we'll do a risk
assessment based on that
and
then we can provide you with a loan
pretty fast
compared to a bank we can do it
within 24 hours usually but our fastest
conversion is is four so if you compare
that to the typical bank loan then we're
super fast
yeah then one last note here is that
lending money
is super easy if you have an e-bomb
number i can transfer you money the
trick is really to get it back and
that's what our business is all about of
course
then to introduce
i gave him a name our gatekeeper is
called patrick he works for the risk
team
and he's really responsible for lending
out the money and he monitors her
portfolio as well and of course like
everyone working in the banking world
the finance world he loves to use excel
and yeah patrick is our main
objective during this presentation and
he will come back
is this yes next slide
this is our sign up flow
pretty simple uh you sign up with your
company you supply us with some bank
statements from the last six months
patrick will review
your um application and he makes a
decision so yes you're approved you will
get the money from us
and know you're rejected you won't get
any money from us you can go to
competitor or try it with the bank but
yeah patrick is really our gatekeeper he
decides on who gets the money and who
doesn't
um yeah then what do we use for that i
already mentioned bank statements of
course so you can connect your typical
bank like abn amro
ing rabobank we have psd2 support as
well so it's like an api that you
connect and you can read your bank
statements directly but we also use some
third party data so google and we also
get your kvk number so we can get where
your company is based uh how many
employees you have
but of course our main source of data is
transactional data
um
you can see some examples here i'm not
sure if it's readable but the first one
says a transaction from the text
authorities on a certain date
with a certain e-bomb the second one is
from no an individual
j smith also on a certain date and it
also contains a description
and based on these
based on these features we decide
on a label so for example the first one
is from the text authorities and we give
it the label text but the second one
contains the word salary in the
description so we mark it as a salary
payment
yeah and of course we aggregate all of
this this goes to our credit
intelligence engine
and yeah we can get all kinds of
insights based on
this raw data at the beginning
and we don't only use it for
our risk underwriters like patrick but
we also use it for our models of course
yeah then some to give some examples on
the features that we then calculate that
we can calculate from the transactional
data that we then label ourselves
monthly revenues if you have any payment
problems because we recognize those as
well
if you
if you pay salary do you pay enough
salary tax over that how many adapters
do you actually have
do you have other financing parties can
you go
can you get a negative balance at the
bank those are all things that we can
calculate and that we also use for the
models but also provides to our humans
like patrick
but we want to work with patrick because
we want to make his work more efficient
we want to make the work of the risk
team more efficient without scaling the
team
so why do we want to do that yeah we
want to point patrick in the right
direction if you can make
if you can summarize why a client is
good or bad
he can make a faster decision he knows
where to look for
and then we have happier clients because
they get their money sooner
and we're super customer friendly so
this is why we would want to do that
yes
now you would say you can predict the
default uh to predict this so
a bankruptcy or they cannot
pay us back anymore but actually
defaults take a lot of time to develop
of course they have to be your customer
for a pretty long time before
a default is there and our volume is
actually pretty low for defaults so it's
actually hard to predict the default for
experimenting with that now but that's
not what my talk will be about
it's about predicting this
so we try to predict what patrick would
do
for a certain decision so you sign up
with your company patrick makes a
decision but can we predict what patrick
would do
to
point him in the right direction to see
if
if he can make faster decision making
based on his old decision making
and
this sounds a bit weird because you can
also say well you can just ask patrick
what is he what is he looking at what
features is he looking at what is good
what is bad but it turns out
perfect clients go to the bank because
at the bank you can get lower rates and
higher loans it takes a bit longer but
if you're a sophisticated company
it's doable at the bank and you can
compare this with
for example a really nice car everyone
can see that this is a nice car
but what about this one
the exterior looks pretty nice it's also
a mercedes
but
if i open up the hood i'm not a car
expert i don't know where to live what
to listen for
how it drives how it shifts i'm not an
expert in this
a mechanic is so patrick is like our
mechanic
and he knows what to listen for where to
look for so it's not that easy that you
can really
define rules what to look for whether a
client is good or bad it's really a gut
feeling
and
that we want to model so we want to
models patrick we want to model
patrick's cut feeling to make a decision
faster
yes
so the processes i will cover today it's
our signup flow which i just introduced
but also our review flow which will
come after if someone is already our
client then we review them
regularly and that is also a process we
apply machine learning to
so starting with the sign up
so how this one started was that we had
a sign up
then there was a model afterwards that
made a decision
and we would soft approve them so give a
recommendation to approve to patrick
or reject them
but
patrick didn't really
like this he didn't understand just like
the jp morgan
use case the example
the problems were well it came down to
this
what features are actually used in your
model
what are their values and how did it
actually come to this prediction because
you're giving me a recommendation now to
well reject someone or to approve
someone but where is this coming from
can you explain why
so we want to get patrick on board
and i will now introduce you five ways
and how you how we got patrick on board
but how you can do this as well for your
use cases to get your stakeholders to
trust the machine learning models
and this resulted in an improved
collaboration with patrick
more performance models of course but
also a way to get continuous feedback
from our stakeholders to
continuously improve on
so we learn from our mistakes and we
also gain some domain knowledge along
the way so we became a sort of a car
mechanic as well we know what to listen
for and how to model features and
how to take all of this into account
so the first
the first way of introducing
transparency is by showing the features
and
when we calculate
the
features all the raw transactions go
into our model it does all the
aggregation there
and it only gives out the prediction but
we can also return what is actually
going what we calculate what is going in
um
how do we calculate that feature what is
the description of that feature what is
its value
and how important is it for the decision
um
and this is really um
and he said that benefiting the entire
process because
patrick also has features but those are
in excel and he wants to see if the
features that are in this excel sheet
are actually the same as that we
calculate if it actually makes some
sense so this is the first way of
introducing some transparency
um
quite straightforward you can do this as
well return your features show them in
your platform we build our own platform
so for us it's pretty convenient but
yeah
everyone can show this in their
dashboard
the second one is of course shop
who's familiar with shop
and who uses it in production as well
who shows it to his stakeholders
a few okay that's good
a quick introduction to shop
explain future contributions of models
so you can explain
how important is a feature you can get
this from that but also what is the
relationship what is the linear
relationship between one of the features
and the out the outcome of the model so
how does it
you can see here that high feature
values have a more red color and on the
x-axis you can see the shop value so the
impact on the model output
yeah so it explains feature
contributions of models it's commonly
used for
debugging your your machine learning
models
you can do this for a single prediction
you can show this for a single
prediction or you can see the overall
shop values for all of your features but
it turns out that this is extremely
useful to to show to your stakeholders
with every prediction
oh
this is a bit how it works if you
average all your features out
and then apply one of your features you
can see the new expected outcome of your
model so for example in our use case
if you have a bakery and you apply at us
but you and you don't have a tax deficit
for example
then your probability to be approved is
increasing a bit then also if you have a
continuously a positive balance in your
bank account then that is also
positively increasing but if you don't
have your bakery for for a long time for
for example only a year
then it decreases a little
so this is how these plots
work
clickers yes then how a value is
calculated if you have something linear
i will not go into the more interactive
models but for linear models it's quite
straightforward
if you have your partial dependence plot
where you have on the y-axis the
expected value of f of x
while you apply the feature so
everything is averaged out you only
apply that one feature then the shop
value is actually calculated by
the average
expected
fee
expected outcome compared to the um if
you apply the feature
so that the red part is actually your
shop value and this is how all these uh
these plots work and how they they show
the values if you have more complicated
models with interaction effects like
boosting then the work of floyd shopley
really comes in with game theory but
i will not go into that
i have some resources on the next slide
if you are interested in that
this works in practice is that we show
this to our stakeholders to patrick
um for every decision that he is making
to see if it actually makes sense for
him
so for example you can see for this one
that this company doesn't have vat
transactions tax vit transactions and
his days that his balance is sufficient
is only about
half of the time and this already gives
patrick a
indication on where he needs to look at
if it turns out that we made a label
mistake here here but there are tax vat
transactions then you can already cross
this out and the probability to be
approved is higher but it can also
validate the green parts that contribute
to the approval of the of the customer
and validate that
and do
faster decision making
if you want to know more about shop
scott loomborg actually
did a lot in this field he also made the
shop python package and you can actually
also use it for nlp and image
classification so if you have those use
cases i think you can use it for that as
well
then we also have challenges we want to
continuously learn from our stakeholders
we modeled their behavior so to to
improve on that modeling we introduce
challenges
and those work like this
we want to gather feedback patrick's
decisions are all saved in our
application and all decisions are then
compared to his gut so if he's not
consistent because we
train the model on his decision making
then we know
how it works is like this
so there's a sign up patrick makes the
decision he decides to reject someone
but the model also makes the decision
the model decides to approve
someone and then we create a challenge
so how this works
is that
patrick is confronted with this screen
it's already filled in with one when he
fills out the credit application and he
decides to reject someone you reject the
company then everything is blocked for
him and he has to bring in a colleague
to validate if his decision making is
actually correct
they both look at the shop plot
and then give provide us with some
feedback
so that we can include new features
change our decision making in the model
maybe try a different model or
change your entire modeling approach so
in this use case you can see
it says client already makes use of a
rabobank vectoring product there's no
room to add extra financing turns out it
was not in the shop plot
that the company already had financing
so we should do a better job there and
yeah this really fueled our
feedback pipeline
yeah so how how this helps is that shop
is used to explain the model in the
challenge uh so
patrick looks at it his colleague looks
at it and we save that information and
we show it in our dashboard so we
yeah we do we don't have to do anything
to gather feedback we don't have to walk
to their desk we still do of course but
we can just look at the dashboard and
find new ways to improve the model
to
improve our decision making with the
model then there's also monotone
constraints that we're currently
experimenting with
for example there are a few features
that always contribute to the approval
or always negatively impacted decision
for example if you have more revenue
with your company then the
probability to be approved is of course
a lot bigger
but also if you have a
balance
that is good over time then that also
contributes well but if you have a tax
delay then it's not and if you have
other financing parties as well then
it's also not but how can you
explicitly tell your model
you can do so with monotone constraints
you can see an example if you compare
the top plot with the bottom plot is
that top plot goes a bit up and down and
it
doesn't always
like if the feature value gets bigger
doesn't always also
contribute more to the approval for
example
but then yeah with this example came
from xgboost you can really tell your
model to
that an increasing feature always
contributes to the approval or always
negatively impacts the decision
so
yeah especially in fintech if you want
to explain
how things work how features contribute
and you really want to be explicit and
tell your model
this is perfectly possible
yeah and then now of course this is
rather short but we do a lot of
monitoring as well every decision is
monitored every challenge is monitored
everything our risk employees like
patrick do is also monitored we compare
it to our decision making and this way
we really
fuel our feedback loop but also
they can see it as well so if they see
a lot of lots of mistakes by the model
they can tell us as well and provide us
with feedback and this is going really
well
then there's another process
which is the review process once they
are in our system we have to make sure
that they are still financially healthy
because yeah they still need to pay us
money of course so we need to monitor
this a little it can be a lot easier
model it has doesn't have to be that
complicated
so this is our review flow
when you're in our system you will get a
review every one two or three months you
supply us with your bank statement
patrick will make
mixed decisions again if some if a
client is good
then he gets the new review again in one
two or three months but if it's bad then
there's an action we might kick them out
or we lower their credit limit
so the objective here is to really
reduce the manual workload
for reviews because this is quite big
for us but without scaling the team
so a semi-automated review flow where we
predict
if a review needs to be reviewed
manually
if it needs to be reviewed manually then
it goes to patrick but if it's not
required to review it manually then it's
of course good and we wait another one
two or three months and
go in this loop again
well this resulted in 60 reduction in
the manual work
we spotted problems faster and we do
manual work more efficiently again and
it's what turned out to be an easy to
tune system
so how do we do that
using a warning system that contained
business rules so a bit easier than the
first
model
but this was even more easy to
understand for stakeholders it's easy to
pinpoint the problem fast
and it's simple to adjust and tune so it
really works like a traffic light
with the business rules
where do you start a business rule
system is quite nice but where do you
start defining the business rules
well you talk to patrick of course
what rules
what are you looking at what is then a
good value for you what is a bad value
for you and then you can also
test their assumptions
you can see if
if they made
if they did any actions based on what
he's telling you you can really fuel
this with data
and also tell him no if he's not right
about certain
rules and certain values and you can
reflect together
but what if you actually want to
make this a bit more statistically
these rules where
he gives you some features but where do
you draw the thresholds
we use data mining using trees for this
which is a
actually a
way that my colleague came up with
to do this to define business rules
so we train trees
and we train trees per feature with a
depth of one
so if you have pre-processed input
features here we see four
we train the three per feature
so uh we this results in four trees that
every tree decides if something is good
or bad
for the in in the end decision if a
review is good or bad
so how does a tree look like
for example you have the revenue that
they are making divided by the loan that
we provide them with and if that's
bigger than 0.7 then that's a good thing
but if it's
below 0.7 then that's bad and the tree
comes up with this
himself of course and this is then
something again that he can bring back
to patrick saying well statistically
this is the best cutoff for this feature
to decide if a client or review is good
or bad what do you think
oh
and then of course you can combine the
trees so you find an optimal combination
of trees and it turns out that
three two or four
make the best decisions here combined so
how does this combine decision making
then work
well you can get a manual example you
can also tune this of course for example
you need
two beds before it's really bad but for
this case if there's one bad then it's
bad and you should go to the
um
it should go to the manual process it
should go to patrick so we have feature
one which says it's good but then
feature two says it's bad and then well
it's bad so it goes to patrick and then
patrick knows right away oh i should
look into feature 2 because that that
one is giving me a red signal it turns
out to be ok then he's
then he's
way quicker in this decision-making
and then there's also the automatic
example of course
um
if both three says is good then it's
good and it you wait another one two or
three months to uh to go back in the
process
this is then how it looks like in our in
our own system you can see uh it goes
chronological from down to up so uh for
review free everything was okay and the
green ones are activated so those are
active rules the grey ones are you can
still see the values but they are not
they're not contributing to the decision
and you can see in the timeline here
that he's making a bit less money the
revenue is all the way to the left but
he started to
get some payment problems so that's the
the red one here so he out of nowhere he
got two payment problems and he also
built on some tax delay you can see here
as well so that is really to some
something to look into then and then
patrick does this
manual decision making he looks into the
payment problems he starts to look at
the transactions which requires lots of
context which models cannot really
gasp of course so
yeah patrick only looks at that one and
then you can also see the revenue of
course but it turns out that this is not
a problem but it yeah it really sped up
the entire process
yes
this also turns out to be super easy to
maintain
we train these trees as a bit of a
scikit-learn wrapper but out of it comes
a configuration file we can easily
adjust the configuration file
yeah because the rules are super simple
to adjust when something changes in our
business process for example
construction companies are having a hard
time and we should be more strict then
it's super easy to adjust this
configuration file and it's pretty hard
to actually tell model and retrain and
stuff
and it's also easy to monitor every rule
so we can see for our entire portfolio
who is having payment problems who has a
decreasing revenue who is not paying his
taxes so we use all of the this in our
monitoring as well to get like an entire
overview
while looking ahead could we increase
the performance of this super simple
model
yes you can actually check it out in our
blog which is florian.tech
so that's that
concluding
patrick is on board models are super
understandable
the review work is reduced significantly
nee gives us valuable feedback which is
i think the most important thing and as
the data team we gain the domain
knowledge using this entire
process which is
the the biggest thing that you can do as
a data scientist is to gain domain
knowledge to understand what the
stakeholders are doing
there's also a lot of other cool stuff
we work on nlp to predict transaction
labels we also predict loan amounts and
interest rates now we invest time in ml
ops
and you can join us
we're looking for a machine learning
engineer a data science graduate student
a full stack software engineer and a
data analyst and if you want to contact
me you can reach me on one of those
thanks a lot
[Applause]
i wonder how do
abrupt
economic changes in uh in the country
affect your prediction of your model
yeah just like yeah for example grow at
some point in time growing up game
yeah that's an excellent question yeah
last year
the government decided you don't have to
pay tax anymore
you still have to pay tax but it's like
delayed and then
tax turned out to be a super important
feature for one of our models if you pay
your taxes you're probably financial
financially healthy
and yeah well
no company was paying tax anymore
and then we rejected all the companies
so in the end we decided to uh just
remove the feature from the model but of
course yeah this is very hard with the
second one it's easier to adjust but
like with the first one it's uh it's
hard
we decided to turn it off and
base it on other features
which turned out pretty well but so you
have to flex please do that
yeah but it needs you can do that yeah
of course you have done you don't have
any training data yeah
so that makes it
now that you've two-part several
features right yeah yeah for sure
thank you
thanks for the presentation i've got a
question about this review process uh
you mentioned that you sometimes change
the business rules right yeah when you
for example know that construction
companies have some struggles
how do you know that certain
areas of business are
in the thermal right now yeah that
really comes from our stakeholders again
so that's uh
patrick again
our risk on the writers
they they really follow the news and
they also look at uh like for example
these um
we have lot yeah
the
price of materials of all is also going
up right now and that is really
something that they feed to the company
like we should watch this and that this
then something we can take into account
i mean like
your client is defaulting yeah now while
we uh we're experimenting with that to
actually predict defaults uh we don't
have a lot so that's also hard of course
but uh
yeah we're experimenting with that
but uh yeah our current prediction
models for the sign up is really
predicting the underwriter's decision
but it's coming up
so it was cool to see that you were
using like monotonic features right so
put a little bit domain knowledge extra
in there but then i started wondering
well i mean technically if someone's
asking for like a hundred thousand
dollar loan but they accidentally turned
that into a 10 billion dollar loan
because they had a typo or something
yeah then you could say well hang on
that's not monotonic we should
oh but then again that's also an outlier
i started wondering yeah do you do
anything with outliers in that sense
because i imagine outliers are more of a
risk when you're doing monotonic stuff
as well
uh yeah so it's really something that we
don't do in production right now but
it's that we're experimenting with but
of course it's also capped
the the max loan is really as a constant
in our
code base of course and
yeah
yeah of course there's also human input
so for example how much do you think you
will make this year and how much do you
think
you need from us and we see quite some
outliers in there that's true
like people making way less than they
say they are and then yeah well it's uh
it's not contributing a lot it's also
not in the shop plots because it's just
not really important because there's so
much noise in there
one last question
okay thank you
i would like to if you can explain a bit
more detail on the
configuration file and translating into
the rules and monitoring the rules and
how exactly
that happened yeah
let's see
yeah so this is uh
we wrapped this in a
circuit learn model actually
so every tree is just
strained and is saved in this giant
model actually that
contains all the other models
and from there we get the thresholds
just from the scikit-learn decision tree
you can find because it's only one depth
you can find the threshold where it's
splitting it and where it splits it we
yeah we get that out
and put it in the json file
and then feed it to our api
and then our api returns
the features come in it returns whether
a feature is good or is bad and we feed
that back into our main application
which we also built ourselves and then
we show it
using the timeline so it says per
feature if it's good or bad and then we
give it a caller and show it
so that's how we deploy that stuff
you